welches mit allen produkt ist das
richtige für eure haut darf wird erst
jetzt mit teenie oder hier natürlich
[Musik]
freunde der sonne ich bin ich wieder
mein euro chemikerin des vertrauens hab
ich dachte ich bin nicht mehr in die
zellen wasser mit seinen gelben zählen
tücher mit shampoo ist das jetzt eine
neue technologie oder einfach nur ein
marketing-trick das hat auch ihr euch
gefragt alles was ich dazu bisher
gelesen habe ist entweder sehr vage oder
schlicht und einfach falsch
das ist eine chance deswegen wird es
jetzt zeit für dieses video wir werden
heute lernen wie man inhaltsstoffe ließ
damit ihr in zukunft im drogeriemarkt
selbst entscheiden können was gut ist
und was nicht haben erstmal mit dem
namen wie zellen was soll diese
bezeichnung ist aus chemischer sicht
nicht gerade sind und nicht gerade sind
vorne völlig geschah
sobald ihr seife spricht tenside haben
haben wir auch mit zellen damit zählen
sie nichts anderes als gruppierungen von
tensiden in wasser tenside habe ich
schon mal in unserem video zur challenge
erklärt wie heute gehen wir jetzt mal
ein bisschen mehr ins detail denn ich
möchte ja wie gesagt dass wir das hier
alles besser versteht und dafür brauchen
wir chemie you can sitte sind moleküle
die grob so aussehen der eine teil
genannte kopf liebt was das heißt er ist
polar und hydrophilen teil genannt
schwanz hast wasser
das heißt er ist unklar und hydro fall
hätte ausdrücken und hydrophob lee
profil sagen also statt wasser hasn't
fed liebend hier sind am fiel das heißt
sowohl fed liebend als auch wasser leben
obwohl fett und wasser ja sonst nicht
zusammen gehen zu diesen zählen
produkten habe ich inzwischen auch
folgende chemische erklärungen gelesen
nämlich dass die tenside mit ihren
hydrophilen köpfen an das wattepads
binden so dass die hypo vielen schwänze
nach außen gucken und den trägt dann die
einen magneten anziehen aber das ist
quatsch tenside formieren sich zwar
tatsächlich gerne
ordneten strukturen das aber nur auf
molekularer ebene genau genommen machen
sie zwei sachen wenn man sie in wasser
schmeißt nämlich erstens tenside
formieren sich an der oberfläche
dabei schauen die hydrophilen köpfe nach
innen zum wasser in die mikrofone spät
sie nach außen dadurch stabilisieren sie
die grenzfläche zwischen wasser und luft
deswegen seifen auch so schön schäume
zweitens tenside formieren sich zu
zählen das passiert dann eben nicht an
der oberfläche sondern im innern mit
zählen können kugelförmig sein oder
stäbchen für mich oder wurm förmig
hauptsache die hydrophilen köpfe schauen
noch aus dem wasser und die mikrofone
schwänze müssen nicht mit dem wasser zu
tun haben
das ist ja nicht mögen was sie
stattdessen mögen ist dreck schmutz
make-up fette öle also alles was ich
nicht so gut in ra salou ist das alles
wird an dem inneren der zelle
eingeschlossen und mit dem wasser
weggewaschen also hier sind tenside drin
deswegen sind hier auch mit sälen drin
wo mizellen draufsteht sind also auch
mit zellen drin genauso aber auch in
allen anderen tensid heutigen produkten
was auch immer neu ist an dieser
mizellen technologie die die zellen sind
es schon mal nicht denn erzählen gibt es
schon genauso lange wie es sie gibt
ich habe ja gesagt aber ich dann
wenigstens irgendetwas neu oder
besonders an diesen mit allen produkten
oder kaufen wir nur die gleichen
produkte unter einem anderen namen
vermarktet werden die mit zellen
produkte folgendermaßen erstens die
sollen besonders mild sein zu haut- und
zweitens sie sollen besonders effektiv
reinigen und tatsächlich gibt es
verschiedene arten von tensiden die
verschieden mild und verschiedenen
effektiv sind es gibt drei verschiedene
tensid klassen die in gesichts
reinigungsprodukten verwendet werden um
1 an ionische tenside liebe nicht
chemiker keine sorge es kommt gleich ein
paar chemische strukturen aber die ihr
müsst ihr nicht im detail verstehen ich
sage euch auf was ihr auch nur ist die
meisten tenside sind an und schützen sie
dann juni steht für die negative ladung
geht an jüdische tenside sind am
billigsten herzustellen und sie haben
von allen tänzen die stärkste
reinigungskraft den an jüdische gruppen
sind besonders gut in wasserlöslich so
dass der schmutz besonders gut mit dem
wasser entfernt wird aber an jonas
intensive sind auch gleichzeitig die
aggressivsten tenside sie reizen die
haut sie brennen in den augen es hat
auch was mit dem ph-wert zu tun unsere
haut hat einen
sauren ph wert von 55 an jüdische
tenside haben in der regel einen leicht
basische ph wert von etwa 8 was zu
reizen beiträgt wenn also ein produkt
behauptet besonders mild zu hause zu
sein
dann sollten an jüdische zentren
entweder gar nicht drin sein oder sie
sollten relativ weit hinten in der
inhaltsstoff liste stehen der die
inhaltsstoffe liste ist nach menge
geordnet du hier kennt ihr jetzt an
ionische tenside auf der inhalts liste
als mit abstand häufigste an jüdische
tensid ist so dem resultat dass hier
gibt's auch manchmal allerdings wird es
nicht so oft und auch nicht zu viel
verwendet und auch alle naturseifen die
aus 100 prozent kokosöl oder 100%
olivenöl avocado öl hergestellt werden
sind auch zu 100% an jüdische seifen und
gehören hier auch dazu also alle
ionische tenside sind am besten um euer
make up zu entfernen vorausgesetzt ihr
habt eine unempfindlicher haut dann gibt
es noch katholische tenside die sind
positiv geladen vorteile ph wert ist
leicht sauer und damit eher ph neutral
wiederum sind sie teurer in der
herstellung und können schädlich für die
umwelt sein und im gesichts produkten
werden sie ohnehin eigentlich nicht
verwendet deswegen können wir sind an
dieser stelle erst mal ausklammern
nummer zwei nicht ionische tenside nicht
ironisch heißt die hydrophilen gruppen
sie nicht gelernt heißt nicht ironisch
intensive auch besonders mild allerdings
haben sie auch die schwächste
reinigungskraft der hydrophilen teil
kann zum beispiel ein zuckermolekül sein
man erkennt sie meistens in der inhalt
liste als glukose glykosid steht dann am
ende oder sub groß zu groß ist drin nur
vorsicht kürzere glykosid ist
ausnahmsweise kein tensid sondern einen
feuchtigkeitsspender weil kriterien
keine lange fed gruppe ist sondern ein
kleines molekül der hydrophilen teil
kann auch so aussehen diese gruppe nennt
man ppg und entsprechende kennt er sie
auch in der inhaltlichen regierte
tenside sind allerdings umstritten weil
bei deren herstellung kürzere freie
betten entstehen können die in die haut
eindringen können und schädlich sein
könnte und dann gibt es noch bullock sah
mehrere das sind die mildesten aber auch
die mit der schwächsten reinigungskraft
ohne chemiker zu sein seht ihr auf den
ersten
dass der hydrophobe teile und der vierte
teil der produkte mehreren sehr ähnlich
aussehen der polarität unterschied ist
also nicht besonders groß deshalb sind
das auch nicht die stärksten tenside
nichtionische tenside sind also sehr
milch geeignet für sensible haut
allerdings entfernen sie das make up
auch nicht so gut wie an jüdische
tenside müssten also in der inhalts
nächste relativ weit vorne stehen man
braucht relativ viel davon
um eben effektiv reinigen zu können
jetzt gibts aber noch eine goldenen mit
nummer 3 am poth ehre tenside am hotel
tenside gehören auch zu den jüdischen
tensiden ihre hydrophile gruppe ist also
auch geladen
allerdings kann sie sowohl negativ als
auch positiv geladen sein je nach
ph-wert amputierten side sind dort nicht
milder als an ionische tenside brennen
auch nicht in den augen während zb ein
baby shampoo eingesetzt sie haben
außerdem eine ziemlich starke
reinigungskraft kommen nicht ganz an die
am jüdischen dran aber es ist schon
ziemlich ordentlich dafür sind am vortag
tendierte auch in der herstellung am
teuersten es gibt zwei schlagwörter mit
denen ihr am hotel tenside auf der
inhaltliche erkennen könnt ist eine ist
am vor das andere ist peter ihn das sind
aus chemischer sicht also die best
intensive mild und effektiv so mit
diesem wissen könnte jetzt auch schon
selbst beurteilen welche tenside welche
mizellen in speziellen produkten drin
sein sollten damit sie eben mild und
effektiv sind nämlich entweder
amputieren tenside oder größeren mengen
an nichtionische tenside eventuell in
kombination mit einer kleineren menge
anatolischen teams vergleichen wir doch
mal von derselben marke die normalen
produkte mit denen die zellen produkten
hier ist in beiden produkten dasselbe
tun sie drin die man in ein antwort er
ist entschied aus ein gutes tensid und
man muss auch sagen die inhaltsstoffe
liste ist in ecm produkt deutlich kürzer
als hier was auch ein vorteil sein kann
für sensible haut aber hier ist eine
mischung von tensiden drin in beiden
produkten dieselben auch in derselben
reihenfolge und auch sonst sehe ich
nicht viel wesentlichen unterschied hier
sind in dem normalen produkt sogar
bessere tenside drin als beide mit
zellen wenn man so möchte den nicht mehr
am vortag
fazit das neue an die zellen technologie
sind nicht die zellen und auch nicht die
inhaltsstoffe sondern vor allem das
marketing wie gut sind eure tenside zu
hause habt ihr euch gute produkte
ausgesucht schaut es nach schreibe es in
die kommentare
wenn ihr noch mehr themen vorschläge
habt auch die erde damit in die
kommentare
die ent card freunde wir sehen uns in
der endphase ein grimme online preis
schwer es ist das letzte mal dass ich
euch fragen
ich brauche eure reise schon abgestimmt
wird das ziel nicht die freude hält wer
zum wollten ist jetzt auch die
allerletzte chance dass sporting geht
ein paar tage es hat derzeit wenig
spargel zum wiederholten mal frage
wollt ihr für uns abstimmen
[Musik]
ich bin
das ich und stark
ich mache
[Musik]
ich brauch mal ran
linke der wie die beschreibung
[Musik]